[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale et régionale en 26
minutes
tout de suite les titres de ce mardi 12
juin le département des yvelines de
nouveau touchée par les inondations
conséquence de fortes pluies de la nuit
dernière et et la soirée d'hier
il est tombé à certains endroits
l'équivalent d'un mois de précipitations
une météo qui a causé forcément de
nombreuses perturbations et incidents
sur le territoire point complet à suivre
c'était hier l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines s'est engagé
encore plus pour l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes
l établissement a signé une convention
pour une communication sans stéréotype
de sexe un document qui s'accompagne
d'une dizaine de recommandations
et puis il se tient ce week end à
versailles le tournoi de rugby cette de
coeur revient pour sa septième édition
un rendez vous caritatif au profit
d'associations
on en parle avec benoît quand co
organisateur de ce tournoi
invité de ce journal également
jean-claude lagon président de
l'association à 10 gratuite son combat
obtenir la gratuité des tronçons
franciliens des autoroutes a10 a11 il
est avec moi un plateau il répondra à
nos questions tout à l'heure dans ce
journal est l'équivalent d'un mois de
pluie tombés en moins de 24 heures
résultat une sagres et une sacrée
pagaille dans les yvelines ce mardi
qu'ils ne sont plus à placer ce soir en
vigilance orange par météo france ce
matin au réveil certaines communes du
département se sont retrouvés les pieds
dans l'eau plusieurs grandeurs d'entre
elles ont activé leur plan communal de
sauvegarde plus de 1000 interventions de
pompiers des yvelines ont été
nécessaires des groupes scolaires fermés
à saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse de nombreuses
pannes d'électricité et des zones qui
ont même été évacuées comme aux mureaux
comme vous le voyez sur ces images trois
quartiers ont été inondés ceux des
musiciens de la comtesse et des sablons
et forcément avec les intempéries
beaucoup de perturbations sont à noter
dans les yvelines notamment sur le
réseau des transports est l'autoroute
a13 a été coupée toute la journée dans
les deux sens de circulation au niveau
dorval de poissy et d
mureaux l'eau est montée à certains
endroits à plus d'un mètre quarante deux
eaux à 18h à l'heure où je vous parle
une évolution a noté l'a13 a rouvert
dans le sens paris-province de voix
seulement ouverte à la circulation et
sur certains tronçons la vitesse est
limitée
quant aux opérations de ceux de pompage
elles se poursuivent mais elles sont à
difficile un car le réseau secondaire
est également inondées elle les voitures
bloquées sur l'autoroute ont pu être
évacués et du côté des transports en
commun ces images impressionnantes ont
fait le tour des médias aujourd'hui une
rame du rer b a déraillé ce matin à 5
heures entre saint-rémy-les-chevreuse et
la gare de courcelles sur yvette en
essonne trois personnes ont été
légèrement blessées
à l'origine de l'incident un glissement
de terrain l'eau a coupé en deux le
talus sur lequel était posé les rails
la ligne est coupée entre
saint-rémy-les-chevreuse et la gare
d'orsay les travaux de remise en état
pourrait durer plusieurs semaines selon
ile-de-france mobilité enfin la journée
a été également très difficile pour les
utilisateurs du des transports à saint
quentin en yvelines en raison des
inondations et d'un défaut
d'alimentation électrique la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines a fonctionné
au ralenti trafic des lignes n uds et du
rer c est totalement interrompu ce mardi
une reprise est très partiels sur la
ligne n et le rer c s'opère depuis 16h30
enfin enfin pour terminer ce point très
complet demain vous devrez encore vous
armer de patience car la grève des
cheminots la sncf se poursuit suite du
15e mouvement pointillés des cheminots
est les prévisions pour les lignes n uds
et le rer c 1 train sur 2 demain
mercredi
un site important pour consulter les
horaires de votre à car la météo et ses
conséquences peuvent modifier ses
prévisions transilien.com ça y est je
vais pouvoir peut-être un peu respirer
et poser mes questions à mon invité en
plateau jean claude lagrange bonsoir
bonsoir on va parler avec vous des
autoroutes on parlait tout à l'heure des
hauteurs de l'autoroute a13 dans le
journal il s'agit là d' autres
autoroutes l'a10 et la rose puisque
votre association l'a10 gratuite vous
êtes président de cette association se
bat pour la gratuité des tronçons
franciliens de la dce et la 11è déjà
pour donner toutes les clés à nos
téléspectateurs de quel tronçon
parle-t-on exactement et pourquoi ces
tronçons sont payants aujourd'hui
voilà bonsoir à nouveau ces tronçons
sont payants depuis l'origine depuis
l'origine de la création de ces
autoroutes a10 a11 en yvelines nous
avons deux grands axes autoroutiers nous
avons la trêve et nous avons la 10ème à
11 là qu'il ya une particularité pour la
10 et la 11 la même particularité
vis-à-vis d'ailleurs des autres
autoroutes franciliennes c'est que cette
autoroute à 10 séances et payantes à
partir de 23 kilomètres de paris
si on la compare par exemple à la trêve
puisque nous sommes dans les yvelines
l'a13 et payantes à 51 km de paris c'est
à de multiples conséquences les
premières conséquences c'est que cette
autoroute dessert des territoires
périurbains très mal desservi par les
transports collectifs donc cette
autoroute a un rôle structurant pour les
trajets domicile travail
ça concerne les populations du sud
yvelines essentiellement oui et pour des
usagers de cette autoroute qui vont
aller travailler tous les jours dans les
bassins d'emploi cité plus au nord c'est
à dire vers saclay vers la ville
nouvelle de saint quentin en yvelines
vers la ville nouvelle d'evry vers massy
palaiseau et bien pour les habitants des
communes du sud yvelines notamment au
niveau des péages d'habiller d'un habile
ça peut coûter jusqu'à 13 100 euros par
an c'est évidemment considérable pour
les budgets des familles sachant que
dans un ménage des fois il faut deux
véhicules compte tenu des destinations
de travail qui sont pas du tout les
mêmes
pourquoi vous avez choisi vous de vous
battre pour la gratuité des trois
accords monde peut-il finalement ce
combat il remonte disons notre combat
spécifique d'associations remonte à 16
ans maintenant mais en fait le statut de
concessions sur ces tronçons a été
contestée depuis le début par les
populations et par les élus mais il y à
16 ans donc on a créé une association
pour pouvoir défendre ce dossier là où
près de l'état est de rassembler les
élus et les populations ensemble pour
faire triompher ce dossier est ce que
vous sentez que la donne a changé avec
la nouvelle présidence nouveau président
de la république pardon et nouveau
gouvernement est ce que la donne a
changé les
les discussions ont évolué depuis un an
sûr que depuis un an après les
bouleversements politiques de l'année
dernière comme les français nous
pouvions avoir un certain espoir que les
choses changent dans ce domaine là comme
dans d'autres et bien malheureusement au
bout d'un an on peut faire un petit
bilan de la situation et le petit bilan
de la situation est plutôt dans le sens
d'une continuité que d'un changement
nous avons été reçus au ministère des
transports il ya quelques temps
maintenant on nous a écouté poliment
sans plus et actuellement il ya vous
savez sans doute qu'ils en discussion
loi d'orientation sur l'immobilité qu'a
fait l'objet aussi d'assises pour la
mobilité et nous sommes impliqués dans
ce débat là mais malheureusement ce
qu'on en pressant aujourd'hui c'est pas
des changements significatifs et en tout
cas pas du tout à la mesure de ce qu'est
les français pourraient attendre
notamment aussi dans le domaine
autoroutier puisque les autoroutes ont
été tenus à l'écart précisément des
réflexions sur la mobilité en france
aujourd'hui bien dommage
le temps file mais si on revient en tout
cas les députés vous vous soutiennent
une quinzaine de parlementaires ce même
dix sept parlementaires aient des
yvelines et de l'essonne qui ont écrit
une lettre commune aux premiers
ministres edouard philippe ils demandent
à être reçues sur le sujet ça veut dire
que oui il ya quand même un soutien à
votre cause sur sur ces gratuite oui un
site il ya un soutien à notre cause et
on sollicite justement de l'évolution
depuis un an de l'évolution de ce
soutien c'est à dire que compte tenu
précisément des réponses dilatoires du
gouvernement
il ya actuellement une mobilisation
forte des parlementaires il ya eu
plusieurs parlementaires de l'essonne et
des yvelines qui ont interpellé le
gouvernement et la ministre des
transports en l'occurrence
malheureusement les réponses n'ont pas
du tout été à la mesure des attentes de
ses parlementaires ça ses premiers
points
deuxième point il y actuellement une
initiative de dix sept parlementaires
encore de l'essonne et des yvelines qui
viennent de demander ensemble une
demande d'entretien auprès du premier
ministre pourquoi auprès du premier
ministre parce que tout simplement la
ministre des transports ne répond pas
alors
à leur demande et puis troisièmement
troisièmement il y actuellement une
demande d'enquêté parlementaire sur la
gestion par l'état des concessions
autoroutières cette enquête
parlementaire évidemment à la une
dimension nationale
mais elle s'appuie précisément sur la
situation des tronçons franciliens d
autoroute à 10 et 11 dernière question
il ya des actions prévues notamment sur
le département des yvelines par votre
association en ce mois de juin il y a eu
et il y a eu plusieurs il y a eu
plusieurs déjà manifestation ce courant
juin il ya eu une manifestation au péage
de dourdan le 30
en fait c'est le thé le 31 mai enfin
bourdon en essonne mais limitrophes des
oui parce que en fait l'autoroute a10
a13 à cheval sur l'essonne et sur les
yvelines non tournant autour dans c dans
l'essonne sauf que le ph dit de dourdan
aider dans les yvelines a glosé sur une
petite commune qui s'appelle l'envié
donc on a occupé le péage pendant toute
la journée en s'adressant aux usagers de
l'a 10 avec le soutien de plusieurs
dizaines de maires qui était présent
aussi avec nous cette autoroute
et puis il ya eu d'autres opérations il
y a actuellement d'autres opérations des
opérations de tractage sur le réseau
secondaire puisque le réseau secondaire
est très impacté par le péage le réseau
secondaire devient une déviation de
l'autoroute parce que les gens
évidemment ils veulent pas quitter le
péage donc prennent le réseau secondaire
pour les travailler on est un réseau
secondaire extrêmement saturé donc on
fait aussi des manifestations sur le
réseau secondaire on arrive à la fin de
cet entretien désolé mais en tout cas on
peut retrouver toute l'actualité de
votre association sur son site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
jean claude ragon d'avoir été avec nous
je vous président de l'association à 10
gratuite
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'engage pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
lu vs qu a signé hier une convention
pour une communication publique sans
stéréotype de sexe porté par le haut
conseil à l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes cette convention est
accompagné d'une dizaine de
recommandations afin d'éviter par
exemple les affiches sexistes ou
féminiser les noms de métiers les
détails de nicolas kirillovitch oublier
les vieilles expressions chef de famille
ou mademoiselle accorder les titres
grades et fonctions selon le sexe en
signant cette convention l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
souhaite lutter contre les
au type caché dans sa communication
qu'elle soit écrite ou visuel c'est un
sujet extrêmement sensible qui touche
les étudiants qui touche les enseignants
et le personnel administratif de pouvoir
avoir lorsqu'on fait par exemple des
fiches d'emploi des fiches de poste
d'avoir candidate candidats candidate
vraiment de d'essayer de faire tout ce
qu'on a vu aujourd'hui c'est à dire de
faire attention à qui on de pages en ré
pour espérer combattre efficacement les
stéréotypes le haut conseil à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes propose
au total la mise en place de dix
recommandations accord des métiers usage
du féminin et du masculin dans les
messages
pour la communication visuelle évitez
les couleurs douces pour les femmes et
les couleurs sombres pour les hommes du
bon sens pas encore des habitudes que
finalement le langage a été peu
questionné et on a peut questionner son
pouvoir sur les manières de penser et de
concevoir le monde sur les
représentations qu'on se fait des uns et
des autres et des unes et des autres
justement donc n'oublions pas dans
toutes les luttes qu'on a dans toutes
les démarches qu'on a pour promouvoir
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de veiller à olemps gages qui est
utilisé en france seulement huit
universités se sont engagés en faveur de
cette convention
localement lu vs qu espère convaincre
certains de l'imiter
suite de notre dossier de la semaine sur
la coupe du monde de football j - 2
avant le début de la compétition
aujourd'hui focus sur les retombées pour
le département le parcours de l'équipe
de france pourraient avoir à la fois des
conséquences économiques et sportives
décryptage avec michael et le medoro la
carte bleue n'a jamais aussi bien porté
son nom ce mois de juin lunettes de
soleil t-shirt claquettes les produits
dérivés aux couleurs de l'équipe de
france s'arrache dans les boutiques
yvelinoise le best seller le maillot
officiel
aujourd'hui on
même pas besoin de faire de publicité
quoi que ce soit mais qui a quand il est
arrivé la première chose qu une bande
avait le maillot de l'équipe de france
oui il est là pour vous donc demandé de
donner mon avis votre taille et puis je
ferai un plaisir de les vouloir
récupérer au total 6000 euros de
produits qui de france ont été vendus en
une semaine dans ce magasin et le
parcours des bleus en aussi pour encore
booster les ventes jusqu'à épuiser les
stocks
la relecture de soi qu'on n'est jamais à
l'abri de cela bien sûr après je pense
que dès que dès que la coupe du monde va
se lancer
on est aussi cadets par rapport aux
résultats de la france parce qu'aussi
jamais la france commence des matches de
préparation avec des scores fleuves ou
même des victoires
forcément ça va sentir sur les ventes un
engouement qui devrait se propager dans
les bars dans ce pub installé depuis
1998 voisins le bretonneux
les supporters étaient déjà présents ce
samedi 9 juin pour suivre le dernier
match amical contre les états unis
le taux de remplissage devrait encore
augmenter pour les premiers matches
officiels de la coupe du monde c'est sam
sur une soirée où il ya l'équipe de
france qui joue
moi j'ai comme j'ai dit c'est à millions
c'est pas trop mais quand c'est à 20h30
c'est
100 % de remplissage donc
l'établissement est au complet et il
faut réserver pour avoir de la pasqua
pour boire un verre c'est debout et pour
manger ouais faut réserver à l'avancé
puis des places assises valent cher on
va dire au delà du cadre commercial sur
les terrains la coupe du monde est aussi
un moyen d'attirer de nouveaux licenciés
dans les yvelines on a observé une
hausse de 18 % de joueurs après le
dernier mondial au brésil
un phénomène que le président d'honneur
de l'étoile sportive de tram mustapha
larbaoui connaît bien depuis son arrivée
au club en 2003 il ya une telle
concentration de match une telle
concentration d'image une telle
concentration de stars finalement c'est
notre festival de cannes tous les quatre
ans et puis les faits encore une fois
nation donc la france en particulier
forcément forcément oui il ya il ya cet
engagement particulier
aujourd'hui le département compte 39
1817 licencié ce chiffre pourrait
exploser si la france remporte une
deuxième étoile le 15 juillet prochain
en russie
on continue à parler sport dans ce
journal et solidarité aussi la 7e
édition de cet événement se déroule ce
week-end au stade porchefontaine à
versailles le tournoi de rugby
caritative 7 de coeur se déroule samedi
et dimanche c'est au profit de plusieurs
associations caritatives et pour en
parler un invité avec moi en plateau
benoît quand tu sens bon soir bonsoir
vous êtes le co organisateur de ce
tournoi à 7 de coeur alors c'est un
tournoi de rugby à 7 mais pas que il ya
beaucoup d'animations à côté on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler
pourquoi organiser cet événement
caritatif l'association côté ouvert qui
organise de temps cette des coeurs
constitué en 2009 à l'époque on était un
certain nombre de joueurs de rugby à
vouloir partir faire des tournois à
l'étranger l'été chose qu'on a fait la
première année d'accord et en fait on
s'est rendu compte assez vite qu'on
souhaitait lier notre activité rugby à
un volet caritatif puisque benoît et
benoît moreau et moi qui sommes les deux
instigateurs du tournoi sommes touchés
vont relativement près par le handicap
est du coup en fait on a lié notre cette
activité sportive à l'association
syndrome kabuki au départ et donc petit
à petit on a développé des moyens de
collecte et de communication profit de
cette association est en fait au bout de
deux ans de tournoi donc en 2012 on a
décidé on est allé voir la mairie de
versailles et on a décidé de se lancer
dans l'organisation de ce tournoi dont
le format est est très commun au royaume
uni notamment
et du coup l'idée du tournoi c'est que
les associés les équipes qui participent
elles ne nous reverse pas à nos
organisateurs de droits d'inscription
mais collègues de l'argent qui est
directement reversée à des associations
qui ont c'est à dire qu'elle arrive à ce
tournoi en ayant déjà collecté cet
argent exactement en fait l'enjeu pour
nous pour nous organisateurs c'est de
trouver le budget du tournoi et donc de
se passer des frais d'inscription
classique au profit des associations
caritatives
le rugby pour porter justement ces
valeurs de solidarité d'entraidé ce que
c'est un sport idéal c'est un sport
d'équipé
ces véhicules plein de valeurs le rugby
ce que c'est le sport idéal pour
promouvoir justement la solidarité
je ne sais pas si un sport idéal je
pense qu'il ya d'autres sports qui s'y
prêtent très bien maintenant c'est and
sport à ce moment là
on ya joué pendant de nombreuses années
et ça s'est fait comme ça on en réfère
notre sport ça aurait aussi probablement
pu marcher mais oui après c'est vrai que
c'est un sport collectif avec des
valeurs d'entraidé de solidarité et on
se rend compte en fait que les les
équipes sont relativement filer les
équipes qui participent et elle crée des
liens assez forts avec les associations
au profit desquelles elles collectent et
et qui sont ces associations justement
alors il ya cinq associations cette
année l'association syndrome kabuki qui
est celle avec laquelle on est en
partenariat depuis le début ensuite y'a
laurette fugain qui est
tout le monde connaît simplement et
ensuite sont plus petites associations
l'association swing swing du coeur qui
est basée à pau qui distribue du
matériel médical 20 qui achète du
matériel médical notamment destination
d'enfants
ensuite j'ai un trou en tout cas cette
c5 associations sur des domaines variés
la saison nous aussi qui en fait une
association gérée par des personnes
handicapées mentales pour faire valoir
les intérêts justement des personnes
handicapées mentales et la dernière
association c'est l'association cristaux
rugby adapté qui promeut le rugby pour
des personnes handicapées mentales
majeur alors arrêtez moi si je me trompe
l'être l'an passé pour la dernière
édition c'est soixante mille euros qui
avait été récolté 60 du total 65
millions 66,1 collecté est depuis la
première édition on a collecté plus de
140000 euros est l'objectif de cette 7e
édition c'est 85000 euros de collecte
alors parlons du côté sport il ya deux
tournois de rugby à 7 sur un tournoi
masculin et un tournoi féminin alors
l'ia le tournoi masculin qui était qui
et dont c'est la septième édition qui a
lieu le samedi et le dimanche il ya ces
équipes inscrits de cette année il ya un
tournoi féminin qui a lieu le samedi
c'est la deuxième édition on a 6 équipes
inscrites et on a pour la deuxième année
également un tournoi de rugby à 5
d'accord qui va réunir 21 équipes le
dimanche donc face à un gros succès
c'est une forme alternative de rugby et
plus accessible puisqu'il ya pas de
contact et qui a pas de contraintes de
licences administrativement et et on se
rend compte aussi qu'en fait notre
objectif à nous c'est d'augmenter
toujours le montant des collectes et
c'est un public qui est très efficace au
niveau des collectes et sur le tournoi
de rugby à 7 quelles sont les
particularités pour ceux qui connaissent
le rugby à quinze quelles sont les
différences finalement avec cette équipe
et il ya sept joueurs sur le terrain les
mac sont beaucoup plus courts et c'est
beaucoup plus spectaculaire puisqu'il ya
beaucoup plus d espace sur le niveau
c'est un niveau assez élevé notamment
sur le tournoi masculin c'est il ya des
joueurs qui évoluent en pro d2
en fédérale une wii il y avoir quatre ou
cinq équipes cette année dont les
joueurs sont entre la pro d2 et fédérale
une après le rugby à 7 à cet avantage
que des joueurs qui peuvent même jouer à
des niveaux un peu inférieures sont pas
forcément avantagé mais au moins de
difficultés à se mettre au niveau de
joueurs qui évoluent à des niveaux plus
importants parce que le il ya beaucoup
plus d'espacé les caractéristiques du
jour sont vraiment différentes donc un
tournoi de rugby à 7 masculin-féminin un
tournoi de rugby à 5 également il ya
aussi des animations qui seront bien
désert alors il ya un village il ya un
village pour les enfants avec des
structures gonflables les animations du
démaquillage des choses comme ça il ya
un tournant dodgeball de samedi après
midi qui est assez marrant c'est de la
balle au prisonnier déguisés et en fait
pour toutes ces activités par le
dodgeball de rugby à 5 et le rugby à 7
les équipes collègues de des fonds au
profit des associations
l'accès au village enfants et gratuit
et illimitée dans une certaine mesure et
il ya pendant tout le week-end un
barbecue une buvette est en fait notre
parti pris c'est que une fois que nous
organisateurs on à équilibrer le budget
du tournoi tout ce qu'on récupère comme
bénéfices pendant les deux jours du
tournoi on leur verse aux associations
ce qui nous permette de d'équilibrer les
collectes il est reversée aux
associations et je précise puisque on
arrive à la fin de cet entretien qu'il y
à une marraine et un par un pour cette
édition isabelle ithurburu la
journaliste du de canal+ qui présente
jour de rugby sur canal + est le parrain
je les perds du syli chavancy qui est
trois quarts centre au racing métro 92
international et capitaine du racing et
on les remercie tous les deux ils nous
soutiennent quasiment depuis le début et
ils sont d'une aide très précieuse il
voit là ils sont ils sont top et on peut
retrouver toutes les informations sur le
tournoi à 7 de coeur sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas d'écran
merci à benoît campe d'avoir été avec
nous co organisateur de ce tournoi et je
rappelle qu'il est au programme donc ce
week end au stade de porchefontaine à
versailles
on part maintenant pour un voyage à
travers les pays et les siècles vos
guides près de 300 enfants saint
quentinois vous emmène tous à l'opéra
le nom d'un spectacle qu'il présente ce
samedi au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l heure est actuellement répétition
regardez ce reportage de mélanie poquet
et ical et demi d'euros
[Musique]
l'italien n'a plus de secret pour eux
l'opéra non plus dans ce coeur des
enfants des écoles de saint quentin en
yvelines des trappistes dveri roi des
animaux teint est désolant pour toi je
sais mais bon à l'est de bourges
il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui chante fort
nommé j'aime bien les chansons des fois
l'italien y avait un beau coup blanche
ça fait j'aime bien concerner tous les
beaux ils sont trés turin
à parler c'est chanter et en même temps
quand on chante on apprend on apprend
quelques mots quelques langues comme
l'italien en chantant surtout l'italien
ils répètent depuis le mois d'octobre
pour emmener le public au voyage un
voyage historique et musical au coeur de
l'opéra une création de pierre calme les
c'est un scénario où on va raconter on
va parler des personnages ont parlé d'
orphée on va parler de papageno on va
parler de deux personnages connus
d'auteurs connus deux pays ont fait de
la géographie ont fait l'histoire ont
fait la mythologie grecque ont fait du
texte italien et 7,1 c'est un projet
très globale pour eux et des répétitions
hebdomadaires d'une heure au sein des
écoles élémentaires porté par
l'association de promotion de la musique
classique
tout est nouveau pour eux mêmes la la la
bonne respiration pour le chant est
nouveau il faut chanter des textes en
français ou en italien sur des mélodies
pas toujours très facile donc tout est
nouveau mais c'est à nous de leur faire
aimer cette star plus que quelques jours
de répétition avant de rejoindre la
scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pour le moment les 300 élèves répètent
encore leurs gammes
gina musique pour terminer ce journal
notre portrait de la semaine est
consacrée à fab m cet artiste
rambolitains a notamment déjà fait la
première partie de renan luce ou encore
sanseverino il est actuellement en
préparation d'un nouvel album mélanie
poquet et nicolas landry l'ont rencontré
[Musique]
ce jour-là fab m et son guitariste
arnaud travaillent sur des maquettes le
nouvel album prend forme
après deux ans d'écriture femmes aiment
travail sous son troisième opus
c'est une longue phase de travail
finalement c'est pas forcément celle que
que les gens voient le plus c'est à dire
qu'on met souvent des belles photos ans
quand on arrive en studio mais il ya
tout un travail en amont et c'est ce que
nous sommes en train de faire avec
arnaud et puis j'apprends partage ça
avec les autres musiciens donc un long
travail de plusieurs mois
[Musique]
fab à mayran volutes ans il se lance en
solo en 2007 l'artiste délaisse alors le
rock pour se diriger vers la folk la
chanson française son premier opus or là
mais malgré ça s'est fait naturellement
et puis je pense que même si j'adore le
rock jour j'aimerais vraiment faire du
rock je pense que je suis meilleur en
chanson française camp rock
ne serait ce que pour la voix je ne
pense plus plus feutrée plus posé pour
du rock
c'est pas forcément l'idéal un premier
album vraiment en 2009 qui a qu'à lancer
un petit peu entre guillemets mama ma
carrière et m'a permis d'avoir une
reconnaissance au public et les
professionnels et est magnifié
d'enchaîner sur un deuxième album des
concerts que la tige et les yeux quand
il n'écrit pas ses séances de répétition
faber prépare son nouveau concert après
sanseverino les blérots de ravel
il fait la première partie de goven cers
fab m fait une vingtaine de concerts par
an à rambouillet en ile-de-france et
dans l'hexagone maintenant on se connaît
assez avec les musiciens donc on a plus
besoin de répéter forcément à venir tous
les jours où se voir aussi régulièrement
lorsqu'on a des séries de concerts on va
essayer de se voir deux fois par semaine
pour travailler ici
et donc ça c'est pour les séances
vraiment de répétition concert sinon moi
je vais aller seul
quasiment toutes les semaines
tous les week-ends pour travailler mon
cette guitare whaou travailler ne
serait-ce que des reprises fait de tout
cela s'est écrasé aujourd'hui fab m
travail avec jusqu'à quatre musiciens
amis de longue date ou rencontre récente
je me souviens de
d'apprendre un morceau à la guitare à
fabien qui commençait tout juste la
guitare donc ça date on devait vraiment
avoir enfin moi je devais avoir 14 15
ans est peut-être même 13 et voilà et
depuis il a fait des beaux progrès et il
m'a dépassé
heureusement ça fait à peu près un an où
il m'a recontacté en disant qu'il y
avait besoin d'un guitariste et du coup
bah c'est avec plaisir que je suis venu
j'ai bien fait bah parce que déjà je
connaissais fable savais que ça va être
sympa il reste pas sur sur ses acquis je
vois quand on compose des chansons
laissait toujours de chercher quelque
chose de nouveau de lui se remet en
question aussi une dizaine de chansons
est en préparation favem et ses
musiciens prévoit d'entrer en studio au
mois d'octobre
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal très
bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]